so in the last video when I talked about
the 8 steps of the TCA cycle I mentioned
that there were four enzymes including
the one from the pyruvate dehydrogenase
complex that are allosteric ly regulated
so I want to talk about what Alice
terribly regulates them what are their
effectors so the pyruvate dehydrogenase
complex is has three different
allosteric inhibitors the first one
being lots of ATP so there are lots of
ATP around that's going to inhibit the
pyruvate dehydrogenase complex well why
would that make sense
well lots of ATP indicates a high
indicates a high energy right so the TCA
cycle in the prior video the pyruvate
dehydrogenase complex makes in this
edokko a which will go through the TCA
cycle right and the purpose of that is
to make a bunch of nadh and fadh2 s that
will later go on to give us a lot of
energy a lot of ATP through the electron
transport chain
so if we already have hot lots of energy
we don't need to be creating more so it
makes sense that ATP will inhibit the
pyruvate dehydrogenase complex and
therefore the TCA cycle ok now high
levels of acetyl co a also inhibit the
pyruvate dehydrogenase complex well why
would that make sense
the first and foremost the highest
acetyl co way is the product right it's
the product of this reaction so it's a
product or it's the product so it will
feedback negatively so negative feedback
or feedback inhibition right there's no
sense in creating more right if there's
a bunch of acetyl co a what could that
really mean what this also means so
first of all it's the product so that's
one reason second reason is that if
there's a bunch of acetyl co a what does
that indicate what does that mean that
probably means that the TCA cycle or the
Krebs cycle whatever you want to call it
is not going all the way through right
if there's a bill
of acetyl Kuwait's jesusito Koei's are
supposed to go through the GC a cycle if
they're not going that could mean the
TCA cycle is not working so there's this
this step basically means that the TCA
cycle or the kreb cycle is backed up
okay it's not using up acetyl co a z' so
don't make more do not make more okay
cool
now high NADH why would that inhibit
pyruvate dehydrogenase complex well of
course I'd also it's a product of the
reaction as well right this
dehydrogenase step does make a eh so is
a product okay so it's a product that's
one reason the second reason is that
what does high levels of NADH indicate
if there's a bunch of NADH s around
they're not being reoxidized back into
nad plus if they're not being reoxidized
back in nad plus that probably means
that the electron transport chain is
backed up which is abbreviated as ET see
the electron transport chain is backed
up
okay so nadh is not being re oxidized
back into and ID plusses right so you
don't want to make more if you can't
reoxidized them
okay so that's it for pyruvate
dehydrogenase
now what about citrate synthase
well we'll notice that the first two
allosteric inhibitors are just high ATP
and high NADH those are essentially this
the way the reason why they're out
circuit victors is really the same same
idea same as the above so I don't want
to write that over again that's
essentially like they they are
inhibitors for the same reason that
these in that a high ATP nadh inhibit
the pyruvate dehydrogenase complex one
thing i do want to know is that the
situation place is basically the first
committed step it's the first step of
the pathway so we want to make sure that
this is only occurring if we really need
it well or if we only want to commit to
this pathway so high suction olla go a
high levels of succinylcholine hibbett
this this enzyme from from being active
alright so why would that why would that
be the case well if there's a buildup of
succinylcholine that sucks in Ocoee is
not going on furthering like in in dying
row in the TCA cycle if it's not being
converted right into succinate then that
could indicate that the the krebs cycle
is not going to completion right so this
is again this is the whole idea that the
krebs cycle is backed up I keep using
crabs and TCA enter interchangeably so
forgive me if that's at all confusing
that's the same thing the high levels of
suction of Hawaii indicate that the
krebs cycle is backed up so we don't
want to keep don't want to can you know
commit to the pathway if it's backed up
right what about high levels of citrate
if there's a bunch of citrate that could
also indicate that the krebs cycle is
backed up if citrate is not moving on
further then grab the Krebs cycle is
also is probably backed up so in
addition citrate is also the product
okay so first and foremost citrate
product of that reaction and to this
also indicates that the krebs cycle is
backed up because that's the tray is not
being converted over scroll up a little
bit roll down
okay so isocitrate dehydrogenase it also
is inhibited by high levels of ATP and
high levels of NADH is for the very same
reason as these were and the PD H before
it the indicate higher energy levels and
back up of the e TC so you don't want to
keep making more of those things
however this thing has activators high
amounts of ADP and high amounts of nad
plus what is high amounts of ADP
indicate well if high amounts of ATP
indicated high energy high amounts of
ADP means that the ATP's have been used
up so this is an indicator this
indicates low energy right so if we have
a low energy we want to activate the
Krebs cycle so that we can make more
so make more it makes sense then that
this would be an activator of the
process
what about nad Plus essentially it's
also it also does that it also indicates
low energy right um and essentially if
there's a bunch of nad plus is around
there basically waiting to be reduced to
NADH right there waiting to be reduced
to NADH to be sent to the electron
transport chain to make energy right in
the form of ATP okay that's it that's it
for isocitrate dehydrogenase alpha
ketoglutarate dehydrogenase complex has
three allosteric effectors all the
inhibitors and we've seen all three of
these inhibitors before they're these
three inhibitors are also inhibitors of
citrate synthase so same idea they're
their inhibitors for the same reason
that's basically it what I wanted to
notice in it or what I wanted to note in
addition is that just because something
necessarily makes sense that it would be
an Alistar
factor or an allosteric inhibitor or
activator doesn't mean that it will be
right so for isocitrate dehydrogenase
it's not allosteric lis inhibited by
high levels of succinylcholine said if
it was but for whatever reason it isn't
okay
so I wanted to just point that idea out
is that just because something could
make potentially make sense as you know
to be a an allosteric effector doesn't
necessarily mean that it will be one
okay I just wanted to point that out
hope this was helpful thank you for
watching